as prices at the pump hit an all-time
high here in the valley many have no
choice but just fuel up among them
moving companies that are just trying to
stay afloat victoria saha live with how
a las vegas-based company is offsetting
some of that cost
yeah some moving trucks need to fuel up
using diesel and right here locally
they're at record levels at five five
dollars and 29 cents a gallon for some
movers going across some parts of the
country that could increase which would
question if some of the jobs are worth
the money right now
at triple seven movers owner tom de don
is feeling the wrath of the gas prices
skyrocketing to tell you the truth as a
company that uses
between a thousand to twelve hundred
gallons of gas a day
every every little increase really
affects our pricing the las vegas-based
moving company has 30 trucks around the
country
on average they would spend about forty
thousand dollars a month on gas now
they're spending close to ninety
thousand dollars some places like in los
angeles sometimes even seven dollars a
gallon for diesel
it's making us really having to
reconsider
which jobs are are profitable and which
jobs are not right now he's having to
turn away some customers or increasing
the hourly rate by an extra 20 dollars
now we're having to turn down
deliveries people who are moving to kind
of
middle of nowhere rural america
that will take a 300 400 mile detour
after a full day of just moves around
town we followed one of the moving
trucks to the pump as they fueled up on
diesel this was just half the tank and
it racked up close to 200 dollars
the owner of the company says he's
hoping there will be relief in sight
soon before he has to increase any of
his prices any more to his customers
reporting live tonight victoria saha
live local now